Selena Gomez's mom honors the babies she  miscarried Mandi TV shared an emotional  Instagram post on Monday  remembering Scarlett the daughter she  lost to a miscarriage in 2011 she shared  a series of photos including one where  Gomez has her hand on her mom's pregnant  belly and a throwback where TV is  holding the singer as a baby she wrote  quote December 17th will never be the  same but we decide to celebrate her by  writing her letters on red balloons and  releasing them that same day filming  wrapped on season 2 of 13 reasons why  both TV and Gomez serve as executive  producers on the show boat family is  what matters  blood or not hashtag family 13 made me  smile and feel loved when so needed and  they didn't know she concluded her post  writing fans I want you to know you are  family because I have a huge family and  you are the only ones who remember  you